-Our first guest stars
as Santa Claus
in the new animated comedy
series "Santa Inc.,"
which begins streaming tomorrow
on HBO Max.
Here's the one and only Seth
Rogen, ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ah! Ah!
It's great to see you. Ah!
It's great to see you.
-Good to be here.
-I almost like you
being on a giant screen.
-This is much better.
If I was there, I would ask
if I could touch
Machine Gun Kelly's pants,
though.
[ Laughter ]
-You would want to touch it.
-They look cool.
-Yeah, he's a rock star.
-You can't change your name back
from Machine Gun.
Your name's Machine Gun.
-No.
-Leave it Machine Gun!
-No, no. He goes back.
He goes back and forth, man.
Did you ever have a nickname
or try to have a nickname?
-No. And if I had one
as cool as Machine Gun,
I would stick with it.
If you ever knew me
as Machine Gun Rogen,
that's all you would
ever know me as.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to say happy holidays
to you and your lovely wife.
I know in Canada you celebrate
Thanksgiving earlier
than we celebrate Thanksgiving.
Is that October? Am I way late?
-They do. I didn't celebrate it
growing up, honestly.
And it's because my parents
always told me that
Jewish people did not celebrate
Thanksgiving in Canada.
Something that I later found
to be not true at all.
[ Laughter ]
It was a lie they told us
because they didn't want to go
through, like, the hassle of
doing Thanksgiving.
And so they fabricated
that Jews didn't do that.
-Oh, my God.
-I don't know why, in my head.
-Of course,
you got to believe them
and just go, "Yeah, yeah.
Of course not."
But wow. What a lie.
-It seemed legit.
Jews deprive themselves
of a lot of great things.
[ Laughter ]
We don't eat bacon.
It added up.
If we're not eating bacon,
all bets are off.
Who knows what we're not doing?
So yeah. But now they do it.
It's funny. Now that I have
nephews, they do it.
-I have to ask you about this,
'cause a few weeks ago,
I was watching -- everyone
watching, the big Adele concert
that was this big concert
special, the big spectacle.
And who do I see
in the audience?
Seth Rogen.
-Yeah, I was there.
I was in the front row
of the Adele concert.
And that is as surprising to me
as anyone
because I had no idea
I was attending the taping
of an Adele television special
at all.
I got an invitation --
"Do you want to go to
a small Adele concert,"
is what I remember absorbing.
And I go to my wife Laurie,
"You want to go to this small
Adele concert?"
"Great, sounds fun."
It's at Griffith Park.
That sounds cool.
So, if I'm being honest --
I hate to burst everyone's --
I smoke weed, Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
And me and my wife --
-Breaking news.
Breaking news here.
-I know. It's tough.
But you'll have to
reconcile that.
So we were like,
"It's an Adele concert.
It's in the park."
We smoked a ton of weed.
And we're like,
"We're just gonna go
and enjoy this lovely Adele
concert."
We pull up and we see cranes --
camera cranes.
There's drones flying around.
There's an entire crew there.
And I'm like, "Oh, no, we are
at the filming
of a television special,
I think.
We're on a television show."
And I'm like, "Maybe it's not
that big a television special."
And then the first person I see
is Oprah Winfrey.
And I'm like, "Oh, no. I think
it's a big television special."
-Oh, yeah.
-And then me and my wife
were like, "Okay.
Maybe we can just kind of like
slink into the background."
You know?
Like we'll just sit in the back.
It's fine.
We are not equipped mentally
to deal with
doing this right now, really.
And so we go up to the desk
and they give us our tickets,
and our seat numbers literally
are 1A and 1B.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm like, "Oh, no!"
-It doesn't get bigger!
-That sounds close!
-Yeah, it sounds real close.
-So we go to 1A and 1B,
and we're in the front row.
We're in front-row center.
We're as close as you can
fathomably be. I sit down.
There's like a camera literally
just pointed at my face.
-Do you know Adele?
-I have never met --
No! I don't know Adele!
And if, Adele, you're watching
this, why did you do that?
[ Laughter ]
Because the whole time I'm like,
"There are so many more famous
people than me here
who should be sitting
where I'm sitting."
And I could just, like, feel
them be insulted
that I had such a good seat.
Like, I was in front of Drake.
Like, there's no world where
I should be in front of Drake.
How is that possible?
And I could just feel, like,
Drake's eyes, like, drilling
into the back of my head like,
"Why am I in 3R and he's in 1A?"
I was six rows in front of
Ellen DeGeneres and Kris Jenner.
Like, I truly have no idea
why they did that.
It was truly wild.
-What do you do when the camera
turns on you?
What do you do at
an Adele concert?
Did you clap or sing along or --
-You try to look --
I don't know.
The whole time, I'm like,
"Just try to look cool,"
which is not a healthy thought
to have.
And for me at an Adele --
It was hard for me to look cool
'cause I'm uncomfortable.
I'm too close.
I feel, like, Leonardo DiCaprio
behind me thinking like,
"Did Seth Rogen write
'Rolling in the Deep'?
Is that why he's so close?"
[ Laughter ]
I feel out of place.
And so I try to just --
It looked like I very actively
tried to look like I'm enjoying
this Adele concert, which I was.
But I was very distracted by
the fact that I was on camera.
So I was playing the role of
just an undistracted,
normal, cool guy trying to enjoy
an Adele concert.
-Well, weirdly enough, I put
together a quick little montage
of you enjoying
the Adele concert.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no.
-Let's take a look at
Seth Rogen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-It was live.
A lot of standing.
-Yeah.
-Every time, I was just like,
"Are we standing
after every song?"
That was also one of
those things.
"We're standing every time?
Every song?"
-Dude, that's fantastic.
-But everyone I know watched it.
It was -- I think it's the most
popular thing I've ever been in
in my entire life.
There's people who I know
have not watched
my last five movies who have
been texting me, being like,
"That Adele concert looked
incredible."
[ Laughter ]
That's wild.
-You got great reviews.
Good. I'm glad.
-Very good, rave reviews.
-I want to talk to you also,
but I heard -- it's not a rumor.
I guess you actually are
the voice of Donkey Kong
in the new
"Super Mario Bros." movie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I am.
-I think that would be
a dream come true
to anyone who plays video --
I loved "Donkey Kong."
I mean, it's legendary.
-I love "Donkey Kong."
Yeah, and I think --
Yeah, it was an --
It was not an expected call
to get.
As I was playing "Donkey Kong"
as a child,
I never projected myself onto
that character necessarily.
But no, it's a thrill.
My mom is very proud of me.
Everyone's very proud of me.
[ Laughter ]
-Your mom, by the way,
who I follow on Twitter --
I don't know if that's weird
that I follow your mom
on Twitter, but --
-Not at all.
-She makes me laugh.
Your parents have been
to the show many times.
And tell her I said hello.
She sent out this tweet
that made me laugh.
She said...
"My son is Donkey Kong.
Don't really know what to say
about that."
[ Laughter and applause ]
She's got great delivery, man.
She writes good jokes.
[ Laughs ]
-It is funny.
-That's the type of support
and encouragement I get at home
for my career.
-They what made you who you are.
Exactly, right? I love Mom.
I want to talk to you about
your funny new
animated series "Santa Inc."
when we come back.
More with Seth Rogen,
ladies and gentlemen.